[Music]
where's your emergency
they're actively fighting in the street
right now two males
red shirt black shirt
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody stop fighting now
stop fighting now
all right everybody on the fucking girl
now
let's go now
let's go you stay there get on the
fucking ground now get on the ground let
go
get on the ground let go
let go get on the ground let's go back
up now
back up
[Music]
i got two at taser fight's broken up
everybody
[Applause]
get on the ground now
[Music]
roll over
sorry
that's my son okay
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm trying to separate
go go this way go that way
let me go
[Music]
not you boy
you boy your boy some some some but you
ain't
just keep coming out over there
all right
redshirt over there was fighting him
okay i came up to about the show
bro stop fucking spitting bro i got my
look at my volume
red shirt
mail was fighting him okay when i pulled
up
the red shirt's involved yep these are
actively fighting okay i told both him
to separate he sprawls out
i'm looking at him
tackling me
and when i get on the ground
i try to taser him i gotta figure out
what's going on with her
that is
oh yeah yeah
hey yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
hey no no no no no no
yeah
oh
[Music]
goodbye